So let's start.
First, good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to this AACR annual
meeting
symposium, Advanced Antibody Conjugate and Targeted
Therapeutic Platforms. My name is Xinyan Wu.
I'm an assistant professor from Mayo Clinic.
It's my great pleasure to co-chair this session with
Dr. Danielle Townsend, a professor from
the Medical University of South Carolina.
So
antibody drug conjugates and other targeted delivery platforms
are
in a particularly fast-moving phase right now.
The field is no longer just about
can we deliver the payload, but about engineering selectivity,
internalization, payload choice,
pharmacokinetics, widen the
payload choices, and
widen the therapeutic windows, and how we do that in the
context of the heterogeneous antigen expression,
soluble antigen sinks, efflux mechanisms, and
physiological expression in normal tissues.
So accordingly, today's program is
organized
to span
the novel platform
innovation, advanced cytotoxic payloads,
and precision targets.
Before we start, I just want to do some housekeepings.
We have 15 minutes for each presenter.
Ideally, you can finish your presentation within 10 minutes, and
we will leave five minutes for Q&A.
There's a clock here which is counting down.
At 10 minutes, it will
start to blink yellow. If you reach 15 minutes, it will be turning red.
So without further ado, I will let Dr.
Townsend introduce our first speaker.
Hi, everyone. Our first speaker for today is going to be Daniel Chen.
He's the founder and CEO of Synthetic Lab Design,
and he was the former VP and Global Head of the Cancer Immunology
at Genentech. He's had a long and deep history in drug
development, where after receiving a U19 award, he
developed an MHC cellular microarray to detect
and characterize both antigen T cell states.
And he's also been involved in the clinical development of
PD-L1 inhibitors, both in phase I, II, and III.
So we look forward to hearing from him today.
Thank you very much to AACR and the meeting organizers for inviting us.
On behalf of my co-authors, it's a pleasure to present
to you SynthBody. This is a multifunctional, multivalent,
multispecific antibody drug conjugate platform.
These are my disclosures.
Antibody drug conjugates targeting targets like HER2
have
led to exceptional results in patients with HER2 high
breast cancer. In fact, the clinical data around response
rates, complete response rates, and duration of response rates
rival the best cancer therapies we've ever
seen across the field.
However, one of the great challenges for the field of antibody drug
conjugates is that we know that in terms of specific
targets on cancer cells for ADCs, there is
no other candidate target like HER2.
And so it shouldn't be surprising that ADCs against other targets
haven't been able to replicate the power of a drug like in
HER2 and HER2 high breast cancer.
HER2, for example, is expressed at 10 to 100 times
higher levels than other specific tumor-associated
antigens. So at Synthetic Design Lab, we use this
as essentially our North Star. We
hypothesized that rather than trying to discover
another target like HER2 for cancer and antibody
drug conjugates, that we could create a novel platform that
would essentially create combinatorial synthetic
targets to behave like HER2 high, and that we
could do so by creating a platform that used
advanced multi-tiered logic gate control.
We built this technology from the ground up like an engineering company around
design characteristics, and we created the SynthBody platform.
This is our multifunctional, multivalent, multispecific platform.
As you can see in the middle here, SynthBody molecules have
essentially between six, eight, or 12 different
active domains in the construct. We
refer to these as Y6, X8a, and X12.
Y6 on the left generally represents our
rapid prototyping platform, and I'll show you a lot of data
today
using that approach. However, the therapeutics that we're taking into the
clinic generally focus on the X8 and
X12 formats. Of note,
again, most of the data I'll show you today is
utilizing VHH domains in the binding domains, but
we've made these constructs using different
binders. These can be peptide ligand binders.
They can be Fab's. They can essentially be any type of binding
unitThere are a lot of features
around the platform itself, but the one specific one
that I want to call out here for this talk is around the
optimized positioning.
Because the molecule has a number of different binding
domains, we essentially can create these molecules to
organize geometric
conformations of proteins on the surface of the cancer cell.
And this allows us to create some really interesting conditional
binding
properties. Before we talk more about the conditional binding, though, I'll just
note the following, that when we look at these synBody
molecules, the molecular weight of the Y6x8a
and x12 formats are actually quite similar to that of an
IgG.
And
when we measure the hydrodynamic radius, the hydrodynamic
radius is again very similar to that of an IgG.
This is because of the way we design the molecules.
The molecule can take on a more compact shape when it is
moving through the body, particularly moving into
compartments such as the tumor microenvironment.
However, once the molecule has started to bind to the surface of
the cell, it can really utilize the much larger
maximum reach of the molecule. And the reason that's important is
because we're trying to organize communities of proteins
on the surface of a cell. Some of these communities of proteins on
a target cell are in proximity. They may be interacting.
They may be in the same lipid raft. And so being
able to interact with those groupings is really
important. But because of the much longer reach, we can
also simultaneously build in the ability to
organize proteins that are not in proximity.
So these are proteins that may be excluded or may be in
a different lipid raft from
one of the other sets of proteins. And so that becomes really
important around the shape and design of the molecule.
I'll also note on the right one of the most important features
of the synBody platform, and that is the ability to
create, using the architecture of the molecule,
3D geometry on the surface of the cell.
We can create essentially kinetically favorable binding
conformations or geometrically
constrained binding conformations.
And it's really this constrained geometry that allows
us to build in very powerful conditional gates into
the molecule.
So this allows us to build essentially advanced, multi-tiered,
logic-gated smart drugs that can adjust to the expression
of different targets in different tissues and in different
tumor types. So we generally build this with what we call
an AND gate that allows us to bind to very specific anchor
targets on the surface of a cancer cell, after which we utilize
AND gates. AND gates themselves generally can have a
multiplier function behind them.
So these are features that can make the antibody drug
conjugate much more powerful when the early conditions of the
logic gate are fulfilled. I'm going to give you a very simplistic
example of this. So this is now a Y6 synBody
targeting CD38, BCMA, and GPRC5D.
These are obviously multiple myeloma targets.
And you can see here on the left-hand side of this figure
the internalization power of this Y6
synBody. So this is compared against monospecific controls.
And these are log order increases in internalization.
And in fact, what we see is consistent
log order increases in binding strength, internalization,
internalization rate,
trafficking to lysosomes, and payload delivery.
And of course, the translation of that payload delivery, you actually see on the
right side of the cell. So now this is a
BCMA-targeting IgG belantamab, the
approved ADC in the space, compared against the
Y6 synBody that I've already described.
And you can see in vitro potency is on the order of
80-fold stronger in a high-bar myeloma resistance
model. So these are big deltas over traditional approaches
for ADC targeting and ADC killing.
But what's more, we really wanted to dive deep
into understanding the power of the cooperative binding we could
generate. So very quickly, two figures here.
On the left, this is synBody versus combinatorial
combined monospecific ADCs. You can see the power
of cooperative binding is very strong compared to the
combinations. On the right, you see what happens when you have
soluble target. Right? So belantamab
is highly affected by the presence of soluble target,
whereas the cooperative binding essentially makes the synBody
resistant to the presence of soluble target.
But if you're going to only pay attention to a single slide in the
entire talk, this is the one to pay attention to.
So this slide shows the power of the
multivalent, multispecific synBody approach.
So what you see here now is the same synBody in an ADC killing
assay in the same high bar MOL8 myeloma
tumor resistance model. And you can see sort of the olive green
ADC killingEvery other tracing is
essentially a knockout of one of those domains.
So our team essentially replaced each domain
in the Y6 synbody with a null VHH to
show what that domain actually adds to the
overall molecule. And you'll see every single molecule, every single
binder you add, adds more power to the molecule.
And we've seen this consistently from one target to two targets, from two
targets to three targets, from three targets to four.
You continue to add greater power to the overall
molecule.
All right. The remainder of the talk focuses on in vivo data.
So we'll start with develop-ability.
The pharmacology of a novel platform like this is really
critical. We can make synbodies that have absolutely
terrible PK, but we've also learned to make these molecules with
really excellent PK. PK that essentially is
indistinguishable from that of IgG, as you can see here on the left.
But as I noted, we've also, through the course of our experience, started
to understand how we can create molecules in this
space with an entire range of PK profiles.
And in fact, many of the molecules that you see here on the right
are actually molecules that are against the same target, and a bunch of
them are actually the exact same binders where we
change the positioning of the binders, we change the geometry of the
molecule, and you can see how that changes the PK.
So we believe we can actually tune the PK of the
synbody to whatever we
would want for that indication and payload.
And that's important because ADCs are probably one of the
classes of therapeutics where the PK of
your molecule really matters. And you're not just trying to get the
longest PK you can possibly get. And we know that belantamab
in the clinic has the longest half-life of any approved
ADC. It also has the worst payload tox that we've
seen for an ADC, and that would be the ocular tox seen with
belantamab. So we do not always try to
get the longest half-life of the molecule we can get.
It really depends on the target linkers and payloads.
All right, so now here's in vivo efficacy.
You can see this is a dose-ranging experiment in an animal.
A nice dose response. At the highest dose tested
here, we have 100% TGI. We have two CRs that
continue to go out
after completion of dosing.
And no body weight loss in these animals with any of these doses.
Now, compared to an active control, we have belantamab
maf. That's obviously approved molecule
in brown in this high bar model. And then you see the
activity of the synbody at two different doses below that.
But the key here is you're seeing that increased
efficacy in the model for synbody in the setting of a
much reduced exposure. 5X and
2.5X less exposure. Which is critical, again,
for an ADC like this because
in the clinic, those exposures are tightly
linked to the toxicities and
doses you can get to. So for our molecules, if we're going
after something with an MMAE or MMAF payload, we are
not trying to maximize that half-life.
This is an interesting experiment.
So we wanted to actually quantitate the
potency delta between the synbody and a
traditional IgG. So here now we match belantamab
MMAE with our Y6
synbody at a essentially
equivalent efficacy and look for the delta
in potency by measuring the exposure.
And you can see here, this gives you a nice quantitation.
This is an 11X delta in the exposure of the
synbody versus belantamab MMAE.
Now, one of the things that's important to note is this, is any of
these findings specific to the targets or the indication we
looked at? The answer is no. Here's a different synbody.
Now, the synbody is against CD19, CD22,
CD79B. It's compared against polatuzumab, the
excellent ADC against CD79B. You see it in
two different models. On the left is the more permissive
Ramos model. On the right is the high bar HT
NHL treatment resistance model. You essentially see the same
thing. Continued observation of log order increases in the
ADC killing potency of the synbody.
Now, we're running out of time here.
There are four other really quick things I wanted to cover
in brief. One of them is, as you look at these molecules, you can imagine the
number of variables that are present in such a complicated
design are massive. And so initially,
we built these molecules all by hand and iterated over thousands of
constructs. But one of the most important things that we've done
at Synthetic Design Lab is build a high throughput engine.
This is a novel combinatorial engine.
It allows us to select targets in an indication that we're
interested in and essentially integrate
target discovery with optimized
synbody constructs and screening.
So we're essentially able to screen across all of those
variables and describe in high throughput their different
ADC killing characteristics across cell lines expressing
very different levels of each of the targets.
It also allows us to optimize for things like production,
and once optimized, we're seeing production actually similar
or higher than for IgGs. And of course, all of the other
develop-ability characteristics important for a
biologic.Finally, on the slide, we don't just
introduce tumor-associated antigen binders to our molecules.
One of the big multipliers we look at are
multifunctional domains. Domains that drive things like
immune stimulation or chemo sensitization, or a number of
other features. The binders
themselves, we can build these with ADC, with binders that have
tumor microenvironment conditionality in the binder itself,
allowing us to create another layer of the multi-tiered
logic gate. So we get really fine control over
those multipliers. And finally, there's nothing about the platform that
is specific to ADCs or oncology. We've
generated data, as you can see in the lower right, for
non-oncology applications of
this platform. So in conclusion, the
SynThBody platform is a novel multifunctional,
multivalent, multi-specific format
that allows the creation of combinatorial
synthetic targets for antibody-drug conjugates.
It demonstrates consistent log order increases in binding,
internalization, internalization rate, trafficking to
lysosomes, payload delivery, in vitro and in vivo
ADC potency over active controls.
We are able to build these things with advanced multi-tiered
logic gate control. Essentially, the SynThBody acts like a
smart drug that can adapt to a different patient's
cancer type differently.
We also have been able to create tunable
PK, so we can select the PK based on the
indication, the linker, and the payload.
We have developed the high throughput engine that really makes the whole process
go, integrating discovery and optimization.
And finally, again, the broad applicability beyond
ADCs and beyond oncology. I'd like to thank my co-authors
at Synthetic Design Lab,
and our Synthetic Design Lab employees that
contributed so much on the left side of this list but are not listed as
authors. Also, I'd like to thank our science partners and our
SDL partners. And finally, at Synthetic Design Lab, we
stand on the shoulders of giants in the field of antibody and protein
engineering and in antibody drug conjugates every single
day. Thank you very much.
Because of time, we will only allow one question.
And also,
there are questions online. I think because they cannot come, I will give them
priority. So I will read the online questions. Can you answer?
Sure.
And that you are welcome. I think the speakers will stay a little bit
longer after the talk, and you are welcome to come up and have a discussion with
them. So the online question is, could you comment on the development
of immunogenicity, neutralization antibodies against
SynThBodies?
Yeah. So obviously one of the really important things that you don't want to do
when you create a new technology is make some fantastic
therapeutic approach that is immunogenic in humans.
So I don't know if you saw, it probably went by too fast.
That was actually on our list of design characteristics.
We wanted to build molecules that are non-immunogenic in humans,
and we take a number of different approaches to do so.
So one of the things we do is we've created, essentially
our binders out of a human repertoire.
So these are human repertoire binders.
We also utilize, in each component that we're creating,
we utilize things that we know are non-immunogenic.
And so we go through this list of approaches that essentially
limit the immunogenic risk,
across the entire discovery approach to the molecule.
Thank you.
Thank you. Our next speaker is Felix Hart.
He is Director of Research Unit in Oncology at
Merck in Darmstadt, Germany, and he brings over a decade of
experience in antibody-based cancer therapies.
And he's currently leading all of the in vitro pharmacology of
ADCs and heads this cross-functional
multi-team from discovery to clinical
development.
Thank you very much for the kind introduction, and thanks to the organizers for
giving us the opportunity to present today M7437 on
behalf of the project team. This is our novel
anti-LY6E ADC using a Top1 inhibitor payload.
These are my disclosures.
LY6E is a GPI-anchored membrane protein, with a
three-fingered structure you can see on the left-hand side, and
involved in fetal-placenta fusion, immune regulation, and
virus-host interaction.
In cancer cells, it promotes tumor growth and vascularization and
also processes the
tumor microenvironment. The mRNA expression of LY6E
is correlated with poor overall survival, and on the right-hand side, you
can see that mRNA expression levels are quite high in a number of different
indications. We have depicted here ovarian cancer, head and neck,
pancreatic cancer, as well as non-small cell lung cancer.
In contrast, the expression in normal tissue is limited and
hence it's an attractive ADC target.
And it has already been tested with an MMAE ADC
in a Phase 1 study, where there were signs of activity in
breast cancer and non-small cell lung cancer.
And this is also a benchmark molecule, so I will use
9b12 MMAE in the upcoming slides, where 9b12 is the
binder that had been used for this agent.
We designed M7437 with a high affinity LY6E
binder. We engineered the Fc part in order to avoid
Fc gamma receptor binding by introducing the LALA mutation,
and hence reduce the risk for hematological
toxicities.We used an enzyme cleavable linker,
which was attached to the antibody by transglutaminase
conjugation,
to reach a DAR of four,
where we then have four exotecans connected to this
antibody.
After binding to its target, it gets trafficked into the lysosome, where the
payload is released and then traps DNA top I cleavage
complexes, which results in cancer cell death.
Since exotecan is membrane permeable, it can also
permeate into neighboring cells independent of target expression and
elicit a bystander effect.
In vitro, we confirmed specific target cell binding
to target positive cells, while we don't see any binding to a target
negative cell. This is on the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand side, you can see effective internalization, where we
labeled either the antibody or the ADC with a pH
sensitive dye that results in red fluorescent in acidic
compartments within the cell. And for the two tested
LY6E positive cell lines, we see effective internalization of both
the ADC and the antibody, where we don't see
internalization in the target negative cell line.
Using those cell lines plus additional cell lines, we tested
the in vitro potency. And in pink, you can see
M7437 on the left-hand side. We have high potency
against two LY6E positive cell lines shown here,
while we don't see any unspecific effects on negative cell lines shown on the
right-hand side. In the upper left, you can also see the
comparison of the M7437 potency to
the 9B12 MMAE benchmark molecule, which resulted
in lower potency here.
In vitro, we also assessed the bystander effect, and this was done by
doing co-cultures of target positive cells with target negative
cells. And in this assays, we set it up in a way
that in each condition, we had a constant number of target negative
cells, but then we added different amounts of target
positive cells. So for each treatment, the first bar
represents target negative cells only, and then in the next bar,
we have, for example, 3,000 positive cells being added, and then the
numbers are decreasing.
We then looked at the relative cell counts
compared to the untreated control.
And in pink, you can see that with the highest number of target positive
cells being added to the negative cells, we have a potent
bystander effect, while we don't see an unspecific effect
when we have target negative cells only.
Importantly, the isotype control did not result in unspecific
effects, and we saw superior bystander effect compared to
the green benchmark, the 9B12 MMAE.
And this indicates the potential to also target
tumors where we have more heterogeneous target expression.
We then conducted in vivo efficacy studies, and these are
patient-derived xenograft models, which I will present here.
These are two examples of head and neck
PDX models. In the upper panel was higher expression, and in the
lower panel was lower expression and a heterogeneous target
expression. We either used three administrations or a
single administration at clinically relevant doses.
So the doses were selected and
guided by modeling and simulation in order to reflect the
exposure we expect to reach later in patients.
And what we can see is very strong anti-tumor activity of
M7437 in pink or purple. And it is
superior, as you can see in the lower graph, compared to the green
9B12 MMAE. And we also conjugated
exatecan with a DAR of eight to the same binder, and this
is this bluish color,
where we don't see
very prominent anti-tumor activity.
On this graph, we have two examples for ovarian
cancer PDX models. And again, we see a very
high efficacy of M7437 in pink and purple,
and it is superior to the green MMAE benchmark,
but also the benchmark antibody using an
exatecan payload.
So to summarize the panel of PDX models we
conducted, we depicted it here a bit differently.
So each bar represents a different PDX model among a
range of indications and shows the percent tumor change at
best response. And what we can see that in TNBC, in
ovarian cancer, in head and neck, in
NSCLC, in pancreatic, and in one gastric cancer model,
we have very high anti-tumor activity at this clinical relevant
doses, either after single administration or after three
administrations. In 17 of these models,
we reached this cutoff for preclinical regression,
and eight models showed complete regression.
For those where we had tumor material of the vehicle controls, we
assessed the expression of LY6E by IHC.
And as you can see in this upper panel, which reflects one
PDX each, we have a range of expression levels.
And importantly, we also have two models which are highlighted
with these asterisks, which are characterized by low target expression.
And also, the first model, the TNBC model, has low to medium
expression. And this indicates the potential for an unselected
approach and that we may not have to rely on a
biomarker-based patient stratification or
selection.And
additionally, we tested the activity of our ADC in
comparison to competitors. So we generated a DATO-DXd
analog and looked at the efficacy in three squamous and
SCLC PDX models. And what you can see is,
in the slower part below the graphs, that in each of these three models,
we have expression of both targets, LYS6E and Trop-2,
and that M7437 in pink versus
DATO-DXd in green show superior activity in
each of these models.
Additionally, we tested competitors in ovarian
cancer, and we generated analogs of Rina-S and
Ralu-DXd, which target folate alpha and
kathorin-6. And
we have here three models. They were selected based on mRNA expression.
We have a high LYS6E mRNA expression
and folate alpha and kathorin-6 are expressed at various
degrees of mRNA expression. And what we see is
that with M7437, in the upper left, we have
superior activity compared to both competitors.
In the second model, next to the right, we have superior activity to
Ralu-DXd and Rina-S and M7437
are comparably efficacious. And in the lower left, we see
high efficacy for all three molecules.
And on the right-hand side, you see a gastric cancer PDX
model, which was derived from a patient receiving
Enhertu and who progressed in the first cycle on
Enhertu. And here we see promising efficacy
in this model with primary resistance to Enhertu or
T-DXd.
The preclinical safety was evaluated in a GLP
repeated toxicity study, using cynomolgus
monkeys as pharmacologically relevant species.
And here it was very well tolerated.
And we saw toxicities mainly
characterized by effects on the hematological
system. Lymphocytes, neutrophils, and reticulocytes were
affected, and this was also in line with histopathological
findings in lymphoid organs and the bone marrow.
We investigated the PK and saw that we have
a favorable profile regarding the PK and
a very high stability of the ADC by analyzing both
total antibody and antibody conjugated to the payload.
We saw superimposed curves indicating a very high
stability, which may also be attributed to the
site-specific TGA's conjugation because it is not prone to
retro-Michael, which, for example, is the case for
maleimide conjugated ADCs using cysteine conjugation.
On the right-hand side, you can see in vitro viability assays
using human PBMCs. We looked at different
subtypes, and we identified proliferating NK
cells, that they were sensitive to M7437
treatment, but we didn't see effects on resting NK cells, and
the same was true for B and T cells,
independent of their proliferative state.
So in summary, M7437 is a novel, highly
stable anti-LY6E ADC with a TOP1 inhibitor
payload ekstatine, which was conjugated
with transglutaminase to a DAR of four.
We have high in vitro potency, including a potent bystander
effect, indicating the potential to be effective in
tumors with heterogeneous target expression.
And this was substantiated in our PDX models, where
we saw very high anti-tumor activity in models with a
broad range of expression and a number of different
indications. In addition, we saw superior activity compared to
competitors, and together with an acceptable safety profile
and favorable PK properties, the preclinical data
package supports the further development of M7437.
And recently we have started a phase one with an escalation phase and
an expansion phase,
where we look at safety tolerability, PK, and
preliminary signs of activity in a range of tumor
indications known to have high LYS6E expression.
And with that, I would like to thank you for your attention.
Well, we'll do online first. We have one question from online.
"Congrats to you. Nice talk.
Could you elaborate on co-culture
assay,
looking at bystander killing?"
Yeah. So this assay we presented here is an indirect assay,
so it's a co-culture assay, a classical cell viability with cell Titer
Glow. And we do not discriminate at the end of the
assay the target positive and target negative cells.
But we know indirectly by this addition of more cells, target
positive cells and a lower signal that we have a bystander
effect. We have orthogonal methods using immunofluorescence
or flow cytometry, which we also use to confirm this bystander
effect being present for those ADCs.
We have one question down-
Hi, I'm Andrew Bush from Central New Jersey. That was a really interesting talk.
Thank you. I have two quick questions.
Is there any evidence in the GPI linkage that it's cleaved so that you
have a circulating population that would affect your
ADC?
So we did not see it from the PK profile.
There's a risk for TMDD due to positivity in
NKBT cells, but this is overcome with the doses we use and we
anticipate also in patients. We do not have evidence
for it being shed in zero.
And the second question was the bone marrow toxicity you're seeing,
do you see normal expression of LY6E in the marrow?
And is it
correlated with a phenotype in the LY6E knockout?
Is there a bone marrow phenotype?
So we didn't test in a tox study in knockout.
What we know is the expression on immune cells, so this may also
correlate with this expression there.
Apart from that,
we also have exatecan as a payload, which is known to drive such
toxicity, so it's a bit difficult to discriminate how much would be
added on from the LY6E expression.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
So can I ask one more question? We have 15 seconds.
So, do you know your antibody can actually
recognize the monkey LY6E
as-
Yes. So we tested the affinity for both
cyno and human, and it's a comparable affinity
for both species.
Thank you.
So our next speaker is Neil O'Brien.
He's from UCLA, and his lab plays a leading role
in research focused both on small molecule as well as
antibody-based therapies in oncology.
He's been involved and co-founder of two biotech companies,
Toral Biotherapeutics, as well as 1200 Pharma.
Thank you to ASOR and the chairs of the committee for selecting our abstract
for presentation. Today, I'm going to talk about the preclinical evaluation of
target-mediated clearance and alternative payloads in cadherin 17-directed
antibody drug conjugates.
My disclosures.
So, some background on the target.
Cadherin 17 is a single-pass transmembrane protein involved in
calcium-dependent transport and maintenance of gastrointestinal
architecture. However, in cancer, according to these
TCGA data, mRNA expression of cadherin 17 is
highly expressed in colorectal cancers, pancreas and stomach cancers, so highly
expressed in gastrointestinal cancers, and largely absent from the majority
of normal tissues throughout the body according to these GTEx data, aside
from significant expression in normal colon and normal small
intestine. And these data have created a lot of excitement around this target,
and it's now considered one of the most exciting, or at least it's considered one
of the most exciting emerging targets for antibody-based
therapies. There's multiple antibody drug conjugates, CAR Ts,
bispecific antibodies, bispecific ADCs
in early-stage clinical development, many more in preclinical, and many more in
development outside this country.
There's also a critical point is that clinical efficacy data have yet to be
reported on the target. So here we evaluated the potential of cadherin
17 to act as a target for antibody drug conjugates.
So first, we measured or estimated cadherin 17 protein
expression in a large collection of colorectal cancer
patient samples and saw we could detect expression in about 90% of
samples with high intense staining in the majority of these.
And then in normal tissues, we screened tissue microarrays for a large collection
of normal tissues and only saw expression of the protein in normal
small intestine and normal large intestine.
And when I zoom in here on expression in the normal tissue, you should be able to
see expression of cadherin 17 is localized to the lateral membranes between
cells and absent from the basal and apical membranes, which is a
different expression pattern that you see in cancer.
You get this ubiquitous expression and tends throughout the cell surface.
And these findings have been shown by a couple of other groups, and
this provides a hypothesis by which we think we can
use antibody-based therapies against cadherin 17, given this normal
expression in the colon. This high
ubiquitous expression in the cancer samples that should allow for preferential
binding of your antibody to cadherin 17 in the cancer, and
it's more protected in the normal colon.
So to test this, we generated an antibody drug conjugate.
First, we generated a monoclonal antibody selective for cadherin 17,
generated an ADC with a VC linker, MMAE
DAR4 payload, and then shown that this binds selectively
to cadherin 17-positive cells, no binding to negative cells.
In internalization studies, you can see the monoclonal antibody over 24 hours
completely internalizes, localizes to the lysosome, as does the
antibody drug conjugate at which we start to see cell killing.
And then in xenograft efficacy studies, we see really nice efficacy in these
colorectal cancer or CDX models
that are positive for cadherin 17 shown here.
And we also have nice activity in pancreatic cancer samples that express the
target and then no activity in target negative.
When we got to pharmacokinetic profiling, our
antibody does not cross-react with
mouse cadherin 17. So we
do see nice cross-reactivity with monkeys cadherin 17.
So for our pilot studies, we ran them in cynomolgus monkeys, giving a
single dose of three mgs per kg to three male monkeys of
three mgs per kg of our cadherin 17 ADC and
measured exposure over 28 days.
Our PK data show
an acceptable PK profile for our ADC
in, you can see, gradual degradation of the total ADC
over time, which is consistent with minimal release of free MMAE payload.
Overall, you could say that the half-life of our ADC is on the shorter
side, but still well within limits that's acceptable for antibody drug conjugates.
We then completed IND-enabling studies and
initiated first-in-human study to evaluate safety tolerability exposure
of our now named TORL-3600 moleculeAnd
we got an early signal in patients that we started to see higher than
expected, based on our pre-clinical models, clearance of our antibody drug
conjugates. So we then moved on to see if we could identify
why this may be happening. First mechanism, potential mechanism for this is
clear, is that is target-mediated clearance happening to our
antibody drug conjugate due to binding to normal expression of cadherin 17 in the
colon and small intestine? And then second, we know that
colorectal cancers are high expressers of P-gp pumps, so could
changing payload
somehow improve activity?
So we started by looking at PK. So as I mentioned before,
our antibody doesn't cross-react with mouse cadherin 17.
So we purchased from BioCyteGen a humanized mouse that
uses homologous recombination to express the human cadherin
17 domain
in these animals. We validated this by
staining for using a human-specific antibody to stain for cadherin
in these
express mice. You can see we get nice intense staining in the normal
small and large intestine, no staining in other tissues.
And then in wild-type animals, we see no staining with the human-specific antibody
and then none in our efficacy CD1 nude mice model.
When we zoom in on this staining, you can see this high intense staining in the
lateral membranes between the cells, very similar to what with the pattern that is
observed in human, indicating that this could be a reliable animal or model
for estimating target-mediated clearance.
To do this, we took wild-type mice and these humanized
animals and gave them a single dose of 2.5 mgs of our
cadherin 17 MMAE ADC, collected blood
over 21 days. And in our wild-type animals, you can see
we get nice exposure of our ADC over time.
We get some degradation, but nice exposure.
But in these humanized animals, we see rapid
clearance of the cadherin 17 ADC, both total
ADC and total antibody with complete, almost below the level of
detection within 48 hours of dosing.
So about fourfold higher clearance in these humanized mice, indicating that the
presence of the human cadherin 17 in the gut of these animals is
causing this rapid rate of clearance.
We then went back to investigate payload.
So I think the majority of people in the audience know that antibody drug
conjugates payloads, by their nature, to have bystander activity, are
hydrophobic molecules. MMAE is definitely considered to be a substrate of
these pumps. Exetecan is also a hydrophobic molecule, but less so.
So we wanted to see if switching our payload and our ADC, keeping the exact
same construct, that's VC link or DAR4, but switching out just for the
exetecan payload, and then compare activity of these
molecules in cell line-derived xenografts expressing P-gp in colorectal.
So we identified cell lines that match up the desired profile.
We got four cell lines here in duplicate samples showing
high expression of cadherin 17,
with or without expression of the P-gp pump.
So in control studies, you can see in the absence of P-gp, but the presence of a
cadherin 17, both MMAE and ADC payload have
equal activity at this 2.5 mgs per kg doses.
Negative models, we see no activity.
But then when P-gp is present, there's a stark difference between the
activity of the exetecan-bearing ADC versus the MMAE
ADC. MMAE bearing ADC has no activity
relative to doses. It had activity in P-gp negative, whereas exetecan is
very active. We reproduced this in a second model.
These are the NCI-716s, the same expression profile with the same results
showing preferential activity of exetecan.
So these provide some sort of an association between the expression of P-gp
and the favorable use of an exetecan payload in colorectal.
To functionally validate this, we did some pharmacological inhibition studies.
So we took the cell line that you see here, the LS513, which is
resistant to our cadherin 17 MMAE ADC,
despite seeing strong binding to positive cadherin 17 in these cells.
We know they express P-gp in these cells, so we combined with an inhibitor,
ensequiror or elequiror hydrochloride, in combination with
our antibody-drug conjugate, and you see really nice restoration of responses in
combination. And for control here, we've got the single agent treatment of our two
P-gp pump inhibitors, showing that it is a combined effect.
For further validation, we engineered cells.
So these same LS513 cells you see here,
when we knock out P-gp pump expression, these cells that were
resistant become sensitive in vitro at the indicated concentration.
We proved this again in xenografts.
Back to the wild type I showed on the previous slide.
Exetecan is active in this model, exetecan payload, whereas the
MMAE payload is not. But when we knock out P-gp, we get
complete restoration of MMAE activity.
And then we did the reverse. We took our SNUC1 cells that are P-gp
negative, forced overexpressed, and we see onset or induction of resistance
in vitro. In vivo, we show in the wild type that I showed a
little earlier, you've got equal potency of both ADCs.
But when we express P-gp in these cells,
MMAE loses its activity. So this is strong evidence, head-to-head
comparison, showing that in this environment of high P-gp expressing
colorectal cancer models, exetecan or topoisomerase
inhibitors like exetecan would be the way to go.
So finally, we went back to see, could this switching of
payloads somehow fix the PK liability I described
earlier? So we repeated these studies, this time dosing with our exetecan
ADC in wild type versus humanized mice.
And unfortunately, we saw the exact same effect, that when we switch to the
exetecan payload in the wild type animals, we get the same exposure.
But in the humanized animals, we see this rapid rate of clearance,
which is very similar to what we saw that I showed you earlier for MMAE.As a
final control, we took just the monoclonal antibody, dosed that free
antibody versus the MMAE ADC, dosed the same animals again at
2.5 mgs per kg, and we see the same rate of clearance with the free
antibody as we do with the ADC, indicating that
target-mediated clearance of this ADC is not dependent on the ADC
construct. It's the antibody that is binding to the normal tissue and being
excreted.
So to conclude,
cadherin 17, it's highly expressed in colorectal cancers, localized to the lateral
membranes, and does present an exciting target for antibody drug conjugates.
However, the target-mediated clearance driven by cadherin 17
expression on normal tissues appears to represent a significant pharmacological
challenge against this target.
And although topoisomerase inhibitor payloads such as
exotekin have superiority over MMAE in P-gp
expressing tumors, that suggests we should use those, it does not
mitigate the fundamental PK liability imposed by the tissue
sync for this target.
So this has been a pleasure to work with a team of wonderful scientists and
wonderful people. I don't have time to list them all, but
I want to thank them and then thank you for your attention. I'll take questions.
So there are no questions online, so I'll start with one.
Do you think that the P-gp status could be used to guide that payload choice?
Yes. I think
our pre-clinical data show that
in these high P-gp expressing environment, that a topoisomerase inhibitor
would be the preferential choice.
Now, that would have to be validated clinically to see what the P-gp
levels are expressed in these tissues.
So with clinical support, I think that it does suggest that P-gp is a strong
biomarker for use of those payloads.
Are there any other questions from the audience?
Thank you.
Okay.
You have one more?
Yes, of course. Yeah.
So I just wonder, with your ADCs, do you
observe any anti-tumor immunity that
activated in your mice? Because I noticed you use
nude mice as a control for the humanized mice.
Any reason for that?
Yeah. It's probably inappropriate labeling as humanized.
It's solely humanized for cadherin 17.
It doesn't have a human immune system or anything like that, so we weren't-
Oh, it's still the deficient mouse?
Yeah, it's still immunocompromised mouse-- Sorry, it's immunocompetent
mouse. But
yeah, we-
But in your country, you use nude mice.
Yeah, we use nude mice. Yeah. So we are
controlling for that right now. So we're going to take control black 6 mice and do
that. So we don't expect to see a difference. Good question.
But yeah, we're doing that.
Okay. Great talk. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, our next speaker is Gavin Bennett.
He is the Senior Director of Translation Sciences
at Bicycle Therapeutics, where he's been there for about 13 years,
focusing on the delivery of both payload as well
as radionuclides.
So, thank you to AACR and to the session chairs
for inviting us. It's great to be here presenting
this. I think what we've heard over the last few talks has
been some very varied and elegant ways of
dealing with some of the problems around antibody-based
conjugates. So I'm going to talk you through a slightly
different way of dealing with that. So these are my disclosures.
So what I want to talk to you about is Nuzepha, or nuzephatide
pepidotin, which is a bicycle drug conjugate targeting FA2.
Now, a number of you won't know what a bicycle drug conjugate is.
So we've got a little cartoon on the right-hand side there.
So instead of having an antibody as the directing
antigen targeting entity, we've got a small bicyclic
peptide. So it's a scaffolded peptide,
linked through to the classic kind of structures you've seen in ADCs
of a peptidic cleavable linker and an MMAE cytotoxic.
What this results in then is a molecule which has a high
affinity for FA2,
has exquisite specificity for that.
So binds only to FA2, not to any other
secondary targets, and not even to Fc receptors.
But it's very small. It's only four and a half kilodaltons.
And as such, it's renally cleared, has a half-life of less than an
hour across species and into man.
So Nuzepha has been in clinical trials
or is currently under investigation
in a range of solid tumors.
We've previously released the first-in-human data
from Nuzepha, well tolerated,
demonstrated favorable preliminary anti-tumor activity in a
monotherapy setting, particularly in metastatic urothelial
carcinoma.
And importantly,
the preliminary safety profile is completely
differentiated from previous FA2 targeting
conjugates that were antibody-based, which had
significant hematological toxicity.
So FA2 has been a target of high interest for a number of
years because of expression across a whole range of solid tumors,
and in particular, expression increasing with stage and
grade and associating with poor prognosis.
As I said,
other therapies targeting FA2 have been limited
by significant toxicities,
bothCoagulopathy and hemorrhage and
peripheral neuropathy.
So we still think that there's a significant high unmet
need in FA2 expressing tumors.
And one in particular that we've been looking at is head and neck cancer.
So this is some data from public domain just talking
through
FA2 expression. You can see the papers here describe
not only a high rate of FA2 expression
across
human HNSCC tumors, but also on the
right-hand side, that association with a really poor prognosis.
So that made it interesting for us in terms of a
potential indication. So what we've done is to go ahead
and look at the antitumor activity of NUZEFA
in a series of xenograft models.
So these are, as we might expect from previous
presentations,
simple xenografts. There's three in there, Fadu,
SCC9, and Cal27. All of these would have
established the xenograft and then dosed once weekly
with this bicycle drug conjugate.
So
we talked to, there were a couple of mentions earlier on about expression
levels,
and particularly the difference between HER2 and most other
targets. So we've established the expression levels of
FA2 in these cell lines, and you can see what we've got there, in
terms of number of
antibody binding sites per cell, is in that sort of moderate
range, typical of targets that have been
useful for ADCs. And then we've also gone on and looked
at that expression in the xenografts themselves by IHC.
So this is the first of those cell lines.
So this is the SCC line. It's got a relatively high
expression by FACS and also by H-score.
And so what you can see is it's also a very aggressive and fast-growing
line. So before the end of the treatment
window of 28 days, the animals have reached a humane
endpoint.
But you can see that even with that kind of aggressive phenotype,
the higher two doses, the three and the five mgs per kg, produced a really
significant efficacy.
Reducing cell growth but also moving almost to complete
regression within that 28-day period.
You can see from the body weights, there's very limited impact on the
animals and good tolerability.
If we move then to the second cell line, we see a
similar picture. Again, in this one,
we have more of a
dose response in here. So we've got a clear
distinction between the one, the three, and the five.
But again, at three and five mgs per kg, we're seeing really
significant efficacy,
moving down to almost complete regressions.
Our third cell line then,
very similar. We've got a dose-related
inhibition of cell growth and in this one,
pretty much getting to a sort of stable disease.
Okay, let's try that.
So we were interested then to put this into the context
of previous models that we've looked at.
Obviously, we've done a wide range of xenografts across different
indications as part of moving this forward to the clinic.
And so we have historical data, predominantly on lung and
ovarian, but a wide variety of other xenografts there in the green.
So you can see that when we express efficacy on the Y-axis
versus the FACS expression,
these sit nicely within our expected range of
potency. So what we can say is that we're seeing
significant and robust antitumor activity across
head and neck HNSCC models, consistent
with the previous performance in a wide variety of
xenografts.
We do see the Cal27, which had the lowest membrane
H-score, having the least sensitivity there
compared with the other two.
So
just to summarize then, NUZEFA demonstrated potent
preclinical antitumor activity in FA2-expressing
CDX models of HNSCC at doses which are
clinically relevant.
We saw no limiting tolerability issues during treatment.
And this feeds very well into supporting further
evaluation of targeting FA2 in head and
neck HNSCC.
So as I mentioned, we're
investigating this in Phase 1/2 trials and a
separate Phase 2 trial at the moment in advanced solid tumor types.
And we have a number of other presentations based on NUZEFA
at the moment. So there's a poster going on in the poster hall right now,
and then some further work, including some
clinical data on combinations tomorrow
and some work in pancreatic cancer coming through on
Tuesday.
So I'll finish there. I'd like to just thank the
bicycle staff and collaborators for
all their work in developing this, and in particular, the
clinical investigators, the patients, and their families who've been
involved in the clinical trials. And I'm happy to take questions. Thank you.
So we'll start from an online question first.
Could you please speak as to why bicycle
molecule
has such a different tox
profile compared to other EphA2 on
MMAE ADCs, which shows bleeding tox?
So
yeah, I'll perhaps just address the
last point. So the only molecule
that's been into the clinic as
an antibody drug conjugate didn't have MMAE, it was MMAF.
I think that difference is likely to be quite minor.
What was seen with that molecule was a profound bleeding
toxicity, and that was a coagulopathy.
So, the clotting factors were burnt through
over time, resulting in bleeding.
Now, I think if you have that kind of risk,
then having an antibody with a very
high systemic concentration maintained probably seems like a
bad match.
What we have with the bicycle drug conjugate is a very short
delivery, and we know that we're able to deliver toxin very rapidly
into the tumor because of the good penetration of the bicycle.
And I think what that allows is there's a significant period
of drug-free interval in these models that are
dosed every week. With a half-life of an hour, you've got a
significant period where the animals have no drug presence,
and that enables you really to open that window between
efficacy and toxicity.
Thank you.
Thank you for the nice talk. What is the binding constant, and
what do you plan to do about the half-life, or we just give it as a continuous
infusion?
I'm sorry, what do you mean the binding-
Binding constant of the peptide.
So 2FA2. Well, it's a two-nanomolar binder.
Okay.
But in terms of
overcoming half-life, are you
looking at the fact that half-life is not long enough or?
Right.
Yeah. I think the demonstration is that
half-life is adequate.
I think that the key thing here is why you need a long
half-life.
We know that one of the reasons that you need a long half-life for an antibody
drug conjugate
is to maintain a concentration gradient because of the poor
penetration. The small nature of these molecules means you
don't have poor penetration. You don't have that limitation.
So that allows you to be much more flexible in your dosing schedules, and
we've demonstrated with this molecule,
we published an MCT paper in 2020, which
shows that that episodic delivery is sufficient to
deliver
a dose of MMAE to the tumor, which is sufficient to kill.
It, of course, takes advantage of the fact that the payload
doesn't require a continuous coverage.
So it's about matching the pharmacology of your delivery agent to the
requirements of the target.
Thank you.
Hi, very nice talk. Can you please elaborate more on the structure of the
bifunctional product? So how many payloads do you have?
One.
Only one?
It's a simple small molecule, so it's a scaffolded
bicyclic peptide, a one-to-one linkage to the
payload.
And is it species cross-reactive? Does it-- Okay.
Yes. So the
binding site
is very similar across species, so this binds
with very similar affinity across all the species we've tested.
Okay. Thank you.
Any more question? We have two minutes.
Okay. Can I ask one more question? Okay.
So the bicyclic-- Because our lab has some collaboration
with some labs, they do also cyclic peptides.
Mm-hmm.
So this screening for us, I was just wondering, compared to regular cyclic, the
bicyclic peptide
provide more specificity? And
how you get these peptides, through the
design or just library screening?
So it's a bit of both.
So we start from
phage display.
Ah.
And so we can
display and cyclize on phage, which allows us to then be
able to produce an enormous amount of SAR at a very early
stage.
Mm-hmm.
And at that point, we can then
use that as information for the chemists to really work and make smart
modifications from there. So, yeah, we start off with an
enormous
amount of SAR-
Uh-huh
... that really helps us drive...
It's not just driving the potency and the selectivity, though, because what that
does is also allow us to have a broad number of start
points so that we can work the appropriate physchem to get
the best overall conjugate properties.
Okay. Thank you.
We do have one more again.
So I don't remember if this was for this
compound or it was for the nectin-4 compound, but you published
an MMAF version?
Yep, that's this one.
This one? Okay. And the MMAF version was decidedly less potent.
Yeah.
And I found that a little surprising because I wonder what your
ideas on that were. It's a CDX model, so it's
not
bystander, presumably.
No. So I think the construct that you're referring to
is
a literal substitution of MMAF for MMAE.
So there's still a cleavable linker involved in that.
And I think what it reflects is,
if you think that the bicycle being so much smaller than an
antibody-There's a lot less steric hindrance
around the linkage. So we believe that reflects
a contribution, not just the classic route of
internalization and then release, but that there's also significant
release from the moment you're bound to the cell.
We know there's a lot of Cathepsin B being secreted.
So I think what we've got is a balance of those two activities in
there that's probably slightly different to what you have with an antibody.
Was that a Val-Sit MMA?
Yeah, it was a Val-Sit MMA, yeah.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, our next speaker is David Dorman.
He's the Chief Scientific Officer at White Hawk Therapeutics,
and he has over two decades of oncology and drug discovery and drug
development expertise, and has been involved in antibody drug
conjugate formation for quite a while.
He's also been involved in other companies like Elevation
Oncology, Bolt Biotherapeutics, as well as Gilead
Sciences.
Okay. Thanks so much for the invitation to share with you what we're up to at White
Hawk.
Disclosures. Skip. All right. So MUC16
definitely gets its claim to fame in the ovarian and endometrial cancer world.
The protein itself is thought to have some form of biological function with respect
to tumor cell proliferation, invasion, and perhaps more importantly, I would
say immune evasion
overall.
The most important thing about it to know from the talk is that
CA125, the infamous cancer antigen, of course, in ovarian and
endometrial, is essentially a cleaved product of MUC16.
It's shed at microgram per ml levels
in the bloodstream, if you will, and essentially correlates with
disease progression for the most part in ovarian cancer.
Now, it's also expressed in subsets of pancreatic and lung cancer as
well, so it has potential in that end of the spectrum
as well. But when you look at it relative to other targets, especially in ovarian
cancer, even just looking at RNA, it is, if not
one of the most, it is probably the highest expressed RNA
target. And then what makes it attractive from a targeting perspective is
that it is very low-level expression in normal tissue.
So from an ADC perspective, since that's what we're all talking about, it already
has the secret sauce of a good ADC target.
But not surprisingly, people have tried this before.
And more importantly, my ex-colleagues when I was at Genentech took two shots on
goal for this molecule. And shout out to Bill Male
if he happens to be in the audience for that.
There's two MUC16-targeting antibodies.
One was the standard cysteine conjugated DAR4,
old school classic.
And then the second one was a thiomab platform, which Jagath did
innovate when he was there at Genentech as well.
It demonstrated some interesting data.
They had anywhere between 14% to 42% objective response
rate.
We'll say the objective response rate tended to correlate with higher MUC16
expression.
But the AEs that they had were typical MMIE.
But what was notably different, I will say, for these ADCs, they
targeted the mucin repeat region, which is essentially the part
that
is shed on MUC16 on CA125. Now,
this creates a problem for target-mediated drug disposition.
And for most ADC targets that are shed, it's really not an issue because you can
just dose higher and really that's all your problem is.
But with MUC16, it's a little bit different.
As I said, it's high microgram per ml level, and so it is a factor to
consider. And so in one of the Genentech programs earlier on, they
had to dose significantly high for an MMIE construct to overcome that.
So that said, at White Hawk, we wanted to take a different approach.
We wanted to target the non-shed domain, the part that's remaining on the cell
membrane of MUC16. But we didn't stop there.
We wanted to obviously move away from MMIE as a general concept, wanted
to move to something that's a little bit more leading-edge, we'll call, with
the Topo I platform. And that's exactly what we have at White
Hawk. We have our own proprietary
platform. We design all our ADCs, like everyone you've probably heard in the
audience so far, is from end to end.
We Fc engineer antibodies. I do just want to call out, it's not just
binding the non-shed that's important.
It's got to internalize with greater efficiency than any benchmark antibody that
we throw at it. And so like all antibody engineers will tell you,
epitope always matters where you choose from.
Now, the platform itself, essentially we have a proprietary
Topo I platform. It does not bind any of the drug transporters that you've heard in
the audience before, much like Xethican doesn't either.
DXd does, unfortunately.
And then the linker itself, we use PEG masking to, again,
avoid the hydrophobicity that's imparted by all these payloads.
And then we also use a lysosomal triple peptide that's cleaved in the
lysosome.
Our configuration is a DAR-6, and we also use stability-enhanced in
hydrolysis to give it a much more stable profile.
But the coolest part of our technology we call carbon bridge cysteine repairing.
Essentially, the linkers are connected by carbon
bond, essentially forms a carbon bridge, and it
replaces the disulfides that typically were there in interchain
disulfides between the antibody light chain and heavy chain.
So what you've got now is not just a loaded Topo I
inhibitor ADC, you've got one that's been optimized end to end and has
very high stability. And so let me walk you through some data related to that.
So the first thing is about selection of mAb.
The antibody itself, as I said, has to bind a non-shed portion of
it. And so the first experiment is just taking an ovarian cancer cell line that
does not have MUC16 expressed and just engineer only the little stump, the
part that's left over on the cell surface before
CA125 gets cleaved.And what is noticeable, the left-hand side,
simply just taking the antibody itself that we identified in a screen that
is part of the ADC. You can see it binds with relatively decent affinity,
and it's not imparted, or I should say, impacted at all
by addition of a large amount of CA125 exogenously in
an in vitro assay. And in the right-hand side, we're just using one of the DMAC,
one of the old school Genentech programs antibody as a control here,
because essentially that binds the mucin repeats.
It's not expected to bind that non-shed portion of the protein.
Now, if you look at endogenous levels of expression between these constructs,
what is clear, if you have high or medium levels of MUC16, you have
sub-nanomolar binding capabilities.
And then importantly, if you don't have MUC16, the antibody will not bind the cell.
So first simple check for an ADC targeting antibody.
And now if we take this and now test what happens when
you add exogenous
CA125, you can see pretty clearly that in the left-hand side,
that's the ADC antibody. The HOX16 antibody is
minimally impacted at all from binding the cell, despite using levels of
MUC16 that are greater than 300-fold what you would see upper limit
of normal in ovarian cancer patients.
And now in contrast, if you take the DMAC antibody, the one that was from
Genentech, as expected, it does bind the
CA125, and so you shift the IC50 significantly
22-fold to the right. So all is fitting so far.
So internalization, I would say a critical part I mentioned about any ADC
design, the epitope matters. And what you can see is here we're getting
sub-nanomolar internalization with our antibody in the left-hand
side, and then it's barely impacted by addition of very high
levels of the CA125. And then in contrast that with the
right-hand side, if you take the DMAC antibody that does bind the mucin repeats,
you can see clearly here it's impacted greater than tenfold to internalize in the
cell, not surprisingly, because it competes with the substrate for
binding.
Now, once the ADC's inside the cell, of course, it has to elicit its effect.
And much like some of the previous
folks that we're talking here, it is a topo one inhibitor, so it is expected to
cause DNA damage in the cells. You can do different methods of it.
We're just showing you two. But essentially, you can see if you use some good
gamma H2X stain in, you can see the cells start to light up
green. And not surprisingly, you get a significant increase over isotope
control. Or you can use old-school cleaved PARP Western blots, and
demonstrated there, we're seeing very clearly with the HOX16
ADC, can show decent cleaved PARP after five days
and relative to the isotope control. But what about the killing itself?
Well, here we're just taking the well-known OVCAR3 cell line that
has high levels of MUC16. And what is clear here is
that the ADC itself is given very potent anti,
we'll say, cell viability activity.
When you add exogenous CA125, again, you'll see the same thing.
The ADC itself is minimally impacted.
In contrast to the right-hand side, little change here.
The DMAC antibody here, we've conjugated onto our linker
payload platform that is called CPT-113.
And what is clear is you see substantial shift to the right when you add exogenous
CA125. So overall, very clear binding
does matter.
And then, like others that have presented here, too, the bystander assay is
key for understanding if your ADC is capable of
wiping out some antigen-negative cells.
We think this is important in ovarian cancer because MUC16, it is highly expressed,
but not every cell will have it, depending on the patient.
And so at the left-hand side, we're just showing you what happens to target
positive cells, the OVCAR3, and then the isotope is in the
green. And then in the middle, this is the antigen-negative cell, the
Raji-Luc luciferase assay, similar to some of the previous discussants
here. And then at the right-hand side, now you're looking at just the three-to-one
mixture. We've done it at every mixture you can imagine, up and down the
titration chart, but showing you one here.
An important part is that you can wipe out every single cell, even though
33% of them in this assay are antigen negative.
And so important to point out that these ADCs are capable of
the bystander effect.
Now, in vivo models, these are just a sampling of some that we've done.
But what's important to know are two things.
One is the left-hand side is a CDX, the right-hand side is a PDX, both are
ovarian cancer and both are MUC16 high.
And what is-- You can see, regardless of which graph you're looking at, the
antibody-- or sorry, the ADC is highly capable of causing tumor regressions.
If you look at the left-hand side on the CDX model here, we're comparing DMAC
itself, the original DAR-4 mmee construct at one mg per kg.
And if you compare that to the HOX16 construct, you can see there's a
night and day difference. At that dose, the DMAC is incapable
of causing any regressions, whereas the HOX16 molecule, almost
every single animal is regressed.
There's a few hanging remaining there with caliper measurements.
Now, if you take the same experiment, again with the DMAC antibody, but add it
onto our CPT-113 platform, you do get better than the original
mmee construct and efficacy, but it's still not as good as the
antibody that targets the non-shed domain.
And I think that that's the key point, again, about picking that antibody that
delivers what you intend it to do. So this is all exciting, but what
about the construct itself? How stable is it and how safe is it?
So the stability part can be addressed, first of all, by using the classic in vitro
plasma stability assay. You can take a range of different species and look to see
how much payload is being released off your construct.
So the left-hand side, this is the HOX16.
We did human and plasma in this particular experiment over a course of 21
days to cover the dosing interval that you typically would do in the clinic.
And what you can see is less than 0.4%
of the topo one is actually released from their construct.
And if you don't know, well, how significant is that?
Well, the right-hand side here is Data ODXD straight from their
publication.And this is their DRUX TCAM platform.
And then here, if you compare human and cyno, you can see their numbers are
like 4% or greater. And so what is obvious from
our platform is we're greater than tenfold higher stability.
So that's an in vitro assay. That's cute and all, but what about when it matters
in an NHP?
So we've done all our tox studies, as you can imagine, and then
we've dosed up to 60 mg/kg. That's the highest dose we've tested.
That is the highest non-severely toxic dose that was declared.
And we saw no mortalities, and every finding we found just looked like a Top1
inhibitor payload class of ADC. And so that's important,
because again,
that's a very high dose for a Top1 inhibitor platform.
And then if you measure free payload release, I just showed you the PK curves at
the bottom left there, less than 0.01% of that payload
comes off in an AUC basis. And so what that does is that means you
can dose higher, still have efficacy, but don't have the safety liabilities.
And that's the whole design of what our platform was meant to do.
The half-life itself, it's long. It's 10 to 13 days.
That's a highly stable ADC construct.
And so fitting with that, we took it forward into the clinic,
and essentially, we're in the phase one right now. This is just a summary of it.
I'm seeing the little yellow mark.
I've only got two minutes left, so I'll just say thanks for
listening. And if you've any questions, feel free to ask about it.
So we'll start from online question. There's one online.
Have you thought about testing bystander
effect in vivo models?
Ah, yes. So the PDX models that we look at,
it's not 100% every single cell has MUC16.
It's high expressed, but there's some heterogeneity there.
So it kind of addresses that question.
Like everyone else, we will also look at additional models through time
and can maybe try and get a sense on what's the lower bounds by which we can get
efficacy. But yeah, that's a very key question.
Hello. Thanks for the very nice talk.
I couldn't help to notice that your antibody is consistently
less internalizing and less potent than the DMU
counterpart. So how do you explain the much more potency in vivo?
Is it simply due to the fact that it doesn't bind to the shed antigen?
That's part of it. So the internalization, the only thing that's different is the
max MFI. The actual internalization itself is actually more potent.
It's sub-nanomolar. dMUC is greater than a nanomolar in the data that
we have. So it is better internalizing.
The maximum MFI can be slightly different because it has avidity.
Okay.
But you're absolutely right. However, nonetheless, when it comes to in vivo,
there is an LFCR3 model. There absolutely is a lot of
CE125 being produced, and that is likely one of the
reasons.
Yeah.
But we have compared, and we essentially selected the mAb to be better
internalization than dMUC in a whole molecule. So it is.
Thanks. And another question regarding the dosage.
I could see that in the vary cancer model, you use a dosage of one milligram
per kilogram and usually except you can on Top1 payload dose at five
milligram per kilogram. Can you elaborate on the-
Yeah, sure. So our construct was designed to be stable across
species, right? So we don't want free payload being liberated off.
And so what that means is there's more in the construct to deliver to the tumor.
And then, again, the most important thing, again, I'll say, is the epitope.
If you pick the right epitope, you will get much greater internalization, and
that's why I was pointing out it is sub-nanomolar for internalization.
And so I think just with that all keeps in mind that overall you're getting much
more payload delivered to the cell.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Sure. You're welcome.
Can I ask for the phase one clinical trial, do you have a
patient selection benchmark?
Oh, yeah. We're doing essentially all comers for now.
But
as you can imagine, we are looking at CA125 levels and such
alike as everyone does for ovarian cancer.
And do you have
ovarian and endometrial?
That's right.
Okay.
Yes, absolutely.
Thank you.
Yeah. And since time's up, we have posters on Tuesday morning.
My colleague Cathy Keegan will be presenting both of them simultaneously,
apparently.
Thank you.
Excellent. So our next speaker is Gillian Eskra,
and she is a research scientist in Prisma Lab at the Broad
Institute at MIT, and focusing on
biologics, both antibody as well as ADC.
And she leads the assay development to evolve for the
Prisma platform.
Okay, great. Thank you for that introduction, and thank you for the invitation to
talk today. I'm excited to tell you guys about the Prism Air assay,
and how we're using it to characterize ADCs and antibodies.
These are my disclosures.
So I want to start with an introduction of what the Prism assay, what the Prism
platform is. So essentially, we're an in vitro screening assay in which we
have over 900 unique cancer cell line models.
We span
solid lineages, hematopoietic lineages, and many super cancer subtypes.
Our cell lines are all uniquely bar-coded and pooled together.
We run the assay in a pooled format.
And at the end of the assay, we measure the barcode via sequencing, and this allows
us to have a viability measurement of all 900 plus cell lines in our assay
across various dose points and all of our compounds.
And so while Prism is essentially at its core a viability assay, the real
power comes through integration of the DepMap data sets.
So by combining these viability profiles for these compounds with the
genomics from the DepMap's portal, we're able to do really comprehensive
integrative analysis and identify vulnerabilities for therapeutics,
as well as biomarkers of sensitivity and resistance.
So one of the ways at the road that we're leveraging Prism to study
therapeutics is through the Oncology Reference Library.
And so this is a large screening effort.
So the Oncref project, our goal really is to have a
library in which we've screened essentially all available cancer therapeutics
ranging from the FDA-approved all the way through investigational ones and
generate a resource that we'll make publicly available as a data set for
the scientific community to use.
And so as everyone in this room is very aware,
antibodies and ADCs are an emerging modality that's
gaining a lot of interest and traction.
So we wanted to make sure the Oncref library reflects this by expanding
the library to include this therapeutic modality,
antibodies, and ADCs.
And so within this goal, we wanted to cover a diverse range of
different cancer cell surface targets, including ones for heme and solid
tumor targets, and span different clinically approved antigens as well
as investigational candidates. So, so far to date, we've screened about
50 ADCs in the Prism platform, spanning 25 targets,
which are listed here on the slide, and multiple different payloads and payload
classes.
So our emerging screening results are potentially telling us
something we already know about ADCs, and that is that sensitivity of ADCs
really strongly correlates with the expression of its target antigen.
So here on the left, I'm showing you the box plots here of the ADCs broken
down by their target and colored by the different payloads that we've looked at,
the correlation coefficients with the target antigen.
And what we generally see is really strong negative correlations with our
target expression and sensitivity, so higher expression of our
target antigen that leads to more cell line sensitivity.
Usually, that typically comes out as gene expression, but we also see that also in
copy number amplification as a feature.
And here I just wanted to specifically highlight the clinical stage ADCs that we
screened, in particular, showing that these generally show very strong
target correlations with the antigen target
for these ADCs.
And so one thing that was really important for us to think about and consider given
the pooled format of the Prism screen was what would bystander
activity look like within this format.
And so essentially what we've seen here is that
bystander-capable ADCs and as well as non-bystander
capabilities both show strong target correlations.
And so yeah, again, in the box plots, you can see the different payloads that
we've screened. Again, a variety of payloads with and without bystander
capability. But on the right-hand side, I highlighted just two of those
conjugated to trastuzumab. So in the top row, you can see
trastuzumab conjugated to MMAE as the payload here,
and the bottom the same trastuzumab with the same linker conjugated to the
non-bystander MMAF payload. And on the far right here, I've
highlighted just the HER2 amplified lines showing selective activity, and we
see that both with bystander-capable and non-capable version.
And due to time constraints for the talk today, I don't have a lot of time to get
into the validation work we've done around looking at bystander activity in Prism,
but I do want to say that we've done a lot of thinking and work in this
regards, and it is dependent on the target expression of
the antigen you're looking at within our Prism cell set and as well as the
individual pools in the assay in combination with the particular
ADC payload and linker chemistry that really will
dictate whether or not we see bystander effect in the Prism format.
So as we were working to build this comprehensive screening data set, we
quickly ran into some challenges.
First and foremost being the commercial availability of ADCs.
So essentially we have screened and sourced everything we can get our hands
on commercially. So we're running out of options, they're limited
to come by and then also difficult for us to validate in
QC. Generating custom ADCs is
time-consuming and very expensive.
And for our purposes in screening, a lot of these not really realistic or
feasible to do on a large scale.
And then while unconjugated antibodies are more readily available, these
typically lack their own intrinsic cytotoxic activity.
So in a viability assay like Prism, it'll generally look mostly
inactive.
So in trying to continue to build this data set and screen more targets, we were
thinking of ways that we can get around some of these issues and expand our
screening library for more antibodies so we can look at different surface
targets. And also think about this as a way that in the
development process for ADCs, you can characterize an antibody earlier in the
process before having going down the workflow of developing a
particular antibody for a target into an ADC.
And so what essentially we have developed to come around this was the Prism AIR
assay. So AIR stands for Antibody Internalization Reporter assay.
And the idea of this assay is generally to
mimic the function of an ADC by using a universal secondary
drug conjugate.
So the assay works, essentially we have a Fab drug conjugate that is
conjugated to MMAF. We have a non-cleavable linker.
We couple this with a primary antibody.
Our secondary Fab works with any humanized IgG
antibody. This complex, again, we treat the cells, and
it functions much in a very similar way to an ADC, will get
selective killing of the cells expressing the target antigen for that
primary antibody.
So to validate Prism AIR as a readout, one of the things we did was to compare
the AIR format with the ADC format.
So here I'm showing you the example of tozotamab in which we've screened tozotamab
vedotin, MMAE ADC version, as well as
tozotamab in AIR.
On the left are the heat maps for viability of all the cell lines in this
assay. And then on the right, if you look at the
expression-The gene expression correlations, we see very similar
correlations for the AIR version as well as the ADC version for the
target of this antibody tissue factor or F3.
The scatter plot on the bottom here showing the sensitivity of this, again,
being nicely correlated with expression of its target.
And comparing the ADC
version with the AIR version, we see a strong concordance here, again, also
associated with the expression levels of the target.
So we're continuing to screen in the AIR platform and
build out this data set. So far, we've screened antibodies against 11 different
targets listed here in both the antibody, the AIR
formats, and the ADC format. On the right-hand side, I'm showing you a
scatter plot of the target correlations for the AIR versus the ADC
formats. So we've looked at a variety of different ADCs
with payloads for the same targets here.
The points colored by the payload of the ADC version.
And largely you see good concordance with the target correlations across various
different antibodies and targets.
Where we do see
outliers or differential activity, it tends to be payload-specific
differences. So here, highlighting ceticizumab conjugated
to the SN 38 has a very differential profile compared to
ceticizumab in the AIR format with the MMAF payload.
And in this final slide, I wanted to highlight ways that we think
using PRISM AIR can really help us better understand and characterize
ADCs and antibody targets.
I'm using the example of a panel of four Trop-2 targeting
agents that we've screened in the AIR in ADC format.
So we've screened datopotamab and ceticizumab, again, both targeting
Trop-2 or taxane-2, in AIR and ADCs.
If we start maybe by looking at the ceticizumab here, what we see is
unlike all of the others, where we get very strong correlations with the target,
ceticizumab does not significantly correlate with its target antigen.
And based on what we know about the linker chemistry of ceticizumab, this
is unsurprising, being unstable and releasing free payload.
And indeed, if we look at ceticizumab gavitan compared to just the free payload
alone, these are strongly correlated.
And we also get
biomarkers that are associated with sensitivity to the payload, like
SLAFN11 coming up as biomarkers.
And then if we look at the AIR for the datopotamab
versus the
datopotamab AIR data versus the datopotamab ADC data, one of the things we
were also interested in looking for was looking for differential drivers of linker
payload-specific sensitivity.
So here is a scatter plot, again, plotting datopotamab
deruxtecan DXd payload versus datopotamab AIR with the
MMAF payload. And we were doing a differential expression
analysis to look for drivers of sensitivity, and we can see a bunch of
things pop out here. Expression of these
driving sensitivity to one payload over the other.
I wanted to highlight the SLC46A3 in particular.
This is a lysosomal transporter that has been previously implicated as being
important for activity of ADCs with non-cleavable
linkers. But it was interesting to find this for ours, because the AIR
payload is MMAF, and previous results have shown that this
transporter may not be applicable to MMAF.
However, our data does show that the low expression of this can confer resistance
to particular non-cleavable linkers with the MMF payload.
This is something we've seen consistently across everything we've screened in our
AIR format that we don't see with different ADCs or
different linker payloads.
So to conclude, we think PRISM screening
can shed light on numerous factors that impact ADC activity.
Screening can be used to uncover novel targets, profile
selectivity of candidate antibodies, and identify potentially new patient
populations for therapeutics. We're actively using PRISM AIR to continue
screening antibodies and building our reference data set, which will be made
publicly available in the future.
And we think this will enable us, as well as collaborators who are interested in
screening with us, to functionally validate new surface targets for
ADC development.
With that, I'd like to thank everyone at the Broad and PRISM who's been involved in
this work, as well as funding from the DMPP consortium, and then highlight as well,
if you're interested or want to know more about the PRISM assay, please visit the
posters of my colleagues here on the screen or come to our booth. Thank you.
Any
questions?
So we don't have any questions online either.
Yeah. All right.
I have one question. Great talk and a great platform.
I'm just curious, is the current screening is on 2D cell culture?
Any data on 3D?
The current PRISM screening, yeah, is a 2D format.
For ADCs and biologics, we have not screened in a 3D format.
We've done some work in 3D format looking at inhibitors, but we have yet to get
into looking at ADCs or antibodies in the 3D format yet.
But that's really interesting and
something we hopefully will be able to do in the future.
Okay, great. Yep. Because there's some
differences between 2D and the 3D results.
So we'll be looking forward to the data.
Mm-hmm.
Thanks.
Any questions?
Thank you. Great talk. I have a short question.
Is it possible for bispecific
antibody?
You're asking about bispecific antibodies?
Yes.
So yeah. I didn't show any of that today, but yeah, we have screened bispecifics in
this format. And we do generally see we can pull out
both targets depending on kind of expression profiles.
But yeah, we've successfully been able to screen bispecifics.
Okay. Thank you.
So do you want to, or can I?
You go ahead.
Yeah. So, okay, can I ask a question?
Oh, yeah.
So if you're just looking at the internalization,
have you actually thought about,
can we just fluorescent label it?
Instead of getting another secondary antibody binding to it,
which created a big hindrance for the
structure.
Yeah, if
you're just looking for internalization, yeah, you can use fluorescent probes for
that or even if you want to just look at surface levels.
I think that the value in this is the viability of the functional readout, and if
you are interested in how not just internalization but maybe your
specific linker or payload is working in this setting, it
allows you to do that beyond just what internalization alone can tell you.
Okay, thank you. So I have one comment.
So every time-- I love Dep Map,
and we look at a prism data set, it's amazing.
I was just wondering, because Broad Institute is enriched with so much
resource, facility, high throughput things, as a regular lab,
academic lab, almost we feel like, okay, let you guys do things, we'll just
wait.
Because nowhere else can do almost, even big pharmas
probably cannot.
How do we approach to you? If we have something
interesting, how can we initiate this kind of-
Yeah
... reach out collaboration?
Yeah, we are always-
... principle on that. Yeah
... looking for collaborators to work with us and screen with us.
I think the value of Broad and Prism is, yeah, we're able
to do things and screen at a level I think most other institutes don't have the
capabilities to. I'd say more on maybe the reagent
sourcing and
chemical side of things, we have less experience.
So really, I think collaborators, if we could leverage your
expertise in developing these agents and how to test them in different
various new linkers or payloads, would be something that we, I
guess, don't have necessarily the expertise in, but we could
help provide the screening expertise for them.
Yeah. For example, we have a new antibody. We want to do it.
Can we just write? Who we should write to?
Talk to us.
Okay.
Our email, I asked to put it-
Okay
... somewhere. Yeah, we're always-
So visit to your poster, yes.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Okay, last but not least, our final speaker is
Janive
Hernandez. She's the Executive Director of Biomarkers and Translational
Sciences at Sutro Biopharma, where she leads both
biomarker and companion diagnostics translational
strategies to advance the next generation of
ADCs. She's previously served as Director of
Clinical and Biomarkers at IGM Biosciences
and led biomarker at Genentech.
Thank you to AACR and the organizers for the opportunity to present.
On behalf of my co-authors, I'm really happy to share with you preclinical
data for STRO-004, a tissue factor-targeted
ADC with a DAR8 exatecan payload,
showing compelling efficacy across tissue factor expressing
models and a clinical trial of patient-derived xenografts.
Here's my disclosure. So tissue factor is a type
I transmembrane protein that's involved in blood clotting.
It's normally expressed in sub-endothelium, and it's
overexpressed in a number of solid tumor indications.
Because of this, it serves as an attractive ADC target, and
it's in fact clinically validated with the approval of tesotamab
vedotin, a tissue factor MMAE payload ADC
in cervical cancer in 2021.
However, while tesotamab vedotin and other
first-generation tissue factor ADCs demonstrate clinical efficacy,
they are limited by toxicity as well as other constraints that
limit drug exposure. These are related to
features of the ADC design itself.
For example, the antibody can have an effect on
coagulation function, or it can also have active FC, which can
induce some immune-mediated effects like
ILD. There's also the
cleavable linker. Early
generation linkers can be
unstable. And of course, there's the payload itself.
Most of them are DAR4 MMAE, and we're all familiar with
payload class effects such as toxicity in the eyes, skin,
nerves, as well as bone marrow.
With these limitations in mind, we designed STRO-004 with the
following key features. First is an enhanced antibody with
high affinity and internalization, as well as reduced leading
risk. Next is optimally positioned non-natural
amino acids that enable site-specific conjugation,
leading to a homogeneous
ADC, in this case, a DAR of eight.
This is coupled with a beta-glucuronidase cleavable linker
that enables tumor-selective cleavage and strong
stability while in circulation. And because of an added
hydrophilicity element, this can lead to optimal pharmacokinetic
properties. Of course, there's the payload.
Exatecan is a topoisomerase 1 inhibitor, and it's known to have
potent tumor cell killing as well as high bystander
activity. In addition, it has immunogenic cell death effects.
And finally, STRO-004 doesn't have FC gamma
function, which limits uptake by alveolar
macrophages, and again, it can reduce the risk for interstitial lung
disease.These design features
translate to a better tolerability profile for STRO-04.
And here what I'm showing you is STRO-04 leading to a
much-reduced toxicity compared to the benchmark tissue
factor DAR-4 MMAE in in vitro models of eye
inflammation, skin toxicity, as well as bleeding risk.
In non-human primates, STRO-04 is well-tolerated up to
50 mgs per kg, and there's no significant heme toxicities,
as well as no evidence of bleeding and eye toxicity,
with only mild skin toxicity. There's a long
half-life and very low free payload, and all of these
translates to higher exposure, as reflected by a higher
Cmax and AUC.
And this is important because high exposure can drive delivery of more
payload into tumors.
This is reflected especially well in a setting where you have low tissue
factor expression. And here what I'm showing you is data from the
HCT116 cell CVX model that
has low tissue factor. And you can see the dark blue line is
a result for the STRO-04 with the DAR8
payload exetecan. And you can see that even at a lower
dose, it has greater anti-tumor activity compared
to either a DAR4 exetecan benchmark in the green
line or a DAR4 MMAE benchmark, which is in the
yellow line.
In order to extend these findings and to fully evaluate the
in vivo anti-tumor potential of STRO-04, we
conducted a clinical trial using patient-derived
xenografts.
The goals of this mouse clinical trial, or MCT as we refer to it,
are as follows. First, again, we want to evaluate the anti-tumor
activity across clinically relevant intent to treat solid
tumor indications. Next is we want to compare the activity of
STRO-04 against relevant benchmark ADCs, including both
MMAE as well as Topo-1 ADCs. And finally, we
want to understand the relationship of tissue factor expression, as well
as other biomarkers with anti-tumor activity.
The study design includes head and neck, non-small
cell lung cancer, both adenocarcinoma and squamous, pancreatic, as
well as colorectal cancer. There are around 20 models per
indication, and these are primarily enriched for tissue factor
expression, but we do cover even expression at the lower range.
This is an n equals one or one animal per treatment
design, and all ADCs are administered at a single
5 mg per kg dose. Now, it's important to note that this is a clinically
relevant dose for Topo-1 ADCs,
and this also implies that the results that we find in this
study can be clinically translatable as well.
Even the MMAE ADCs were dosed at 5 mg,
and I just want to note that the clinical dosing for most of these
MMAE ADCs usually
max out at around 2 mgs per kg at their
approved or expansion doses.
I'll be sharing with you interim results from 70 models because
this study is conducted in a rolling enrollment setting.
And here is the overall response. What you can see in this waterfall
plot is that STRO-04 induces deep tumor regressions across
multiple tumor types with an objective response rate of
64% in this setting and a disease control rate of
around 90%.
Importantly, we see responses across diverse tumor types, as
indicated by the different color bars, and the ORRs are
summarized in this table. So around 60% for head and neck,
going up to around 80% for lung, and then
even an impressive 70% for pancreatic.
The responses in CRC is a little bit lower, but this still represents a
significant activity compared to other potential CRC
agents.
In head and neck, we see that STRO-04 drives deeper response and
longer survival versus the approved
TF-MMAE ADC benchmark. We can see that there
is higher ORR with STRO-04, so 57% versus
38%. In addition, there's also sustained
responses with STRO-04 over time, and you can see that in the landmark
ORR plot. This then translates to better
survival, with STRO-04 having median PFS of
around 45 days versus the benchmark at 27 days.
And here in the yellow box, I just note the ORR, the clinical ORR,
for TIVDAK, the tissue factor MMAE in head and neck
cancer. It has an ORR of 16% at
every three-week dosing. It can go as high as
30% to 40% when the dosing frequency is increased to
every two weeks. And what I want to note is that this clinical
ORR is comparable with the ORR for
TF-MMAE that we observe in our MCT study.
But more importantly, we find that the STRO-04 has higher
ORR in this setting.
In pancreatic cancer, which is considered as a
higher bar indication, we see a similar result with higher
ORR for STRO-04 versus the TF-MMAE benchmark, in
this case, 70 versus 50%. Again, the
response is sustained over time, and this is translated into a
survival benefit. And in this instance, the median survival is
not reached for STRO-04.On the yellow box, I
note the ORR for another tissue factor,
MMAE, that's been tested in pancreatic cancer,
MRG-004A. And here, they've seen a
response rate of around 30% at a two mg/kg dosing,
and that's comparable to the TF-MMAE result that we find
in this MCT study. And again, STRO-04 has a higher ORR.
Now, given this compelling efficacy data, we sought to determine
what are the response drivers for STRO-04, and what might contribute to the
variability in responses. Of course, the first thing that we
look at is tissue factor expression.
And what I'm showing you in this scatter plot is percent tumor change on the
Y-axis versus tissue factor expression level, as assessed by
IHC, on the X-axis.
And what we can first clearly see, as highlighted by the gray portion
of the plot, there is evidence of activity across the full tissue
factor expression spectrum.
But we do see that there's a negative slope, as denoted by
the trend line, and that models that have a higher
tissue factor expression have greater tumor shrinkage.
But models that have lower tissue factor expression also have
significant activity, although they might be a little weaker or more
variable. And we're trying to look
exploratorily at potential cutoffs, at least in this
setting. And we find that, again, while a response might be higher in
what we would consider as tissue factor high, there is still
compelling efficacy in models that are tissue factor low.
So we next look at Schlafen 11, which, as mentioned in the earlier talk, is
a biomarker for sensitivity to DNA-damaging agents.
And here, looking at RNA, what we could see is that both
Schlafen 11 as well as tissue factor
have a trend for higher RNA levels in models that respond to
STRO-04.
In contrast, there is no trend for Schlafen 11 with the tissue factor
MMAE, and this is consistent with the mechanism of action of
MMAE versus topoisomerase payload.
Now, interestingly, when we combine the two biomarkers, on the right
side of the plot, what we can see is that models that are
relatively high for both tissue factor and Schlafen 11 have a
higher ORR, and you can see that over here, whereas
models that are relatively low for both have the lowest
ORR when we look at these models.
So finally, we did exploratory gene expression
profiling using a targeted set of genes that
cover ADC targets as well as molecules that are
involved in mechanism of action as well as resistance.
In this unsupervised hierarchical clustering analysis,
we see a number of genes that might be associated
with response to STRO-04, and I just want to note a few of
these. First is tissue factor itself, or
F3, which again, is expected, and as we can see also
from the IHC results, is associated with response to STRO-04.
Then I want to note genes such as CAV1 and
CAVIN1, which are involved in internalization,
again, consistent with mechanism of action.
And finally, it's interesting to note that models that respond to
STRO-04 may have high expression of EGFR, and
this covers even models such as head and neck cancer.
Again, this is interesting because it suggests that maybe proliferative
state or maybe survival of the models might be
impacting their ability to respond to STRO-04.
And so with this, I want to summarize by saying that STRO-04 demonstrates
robust and consistent anti-tumor activity across solid tumor types.
Target expression is associated with the depth of response but
does not fully explain the response variability.
Combined tissue factor and Schlafen 11 can better capture response
heterogeneity, which reflects both delivery of the
payload as well as inherent or intrinsic payload sensitivity.
And finally, because it seems that response might be multifactorial,
this suggests that composite biomarker approaches may improve
translation to the clinic and inform patient stratification or
selection.
Before I close, I want to highlight that STRO-04 is currently under
Phase 1 trial.
There is a poster tomorrow at the morning poster session where the
trials in progress will be presented by one of our investigators,
Dr. David Sommerholer, and I invite you all to look further
into our study. And to close, I just want to thank
the team, everyone at Sutro that contributed to the
creation and the development of this molecule and its ongoing clinical
development. And thank you for your attention, and I'll be happy to answer any
questions.
How are you? Great talk. So this is a little bit out of left field, but
given the rise of spatial biology over the past decade
maybe, and your strong background in biomarkers, I was wondering how Sutro
considers or uses spatial biomarkers or spatial technologies
when developing molecules like STRO-04.
I want to say the base case is, of course, we are aware and we're interested in
how this might impact.
From a practical perspective, I think, first of all, we've seen that
there is responses or activity across a broad range of expression.
So what that translates to is first, our clinical study is essentially taking
all comers, and we're continuously evaluating the results from our mouse
clinical trial. We, of course, have images and slides,
and that's something that we could further explore
down the line.
Great. Thank you.
Congrats for the really strong data.
I have a question to the very beginning of your talk.
I was surprised to see that you went through all the effort to introduce
para-azido phenylalanine by code expansion.
What
made you go this extra mile versus, for example, just
adding engineered cysteines and some stable conjugation?
It's really about having
well-controlled, site-specific and homogeneous
DAR ADCs.
All of this combined, it's not just the PAMF, it's
everything together. It leads to a highly stable molecule.
There's very little payload release systemically.
We think that most of it really occurs in the tumor tissue, and all of it
combined, leads to higher exposure.
I think it's really the stability and the homogeneity
of the DAR that also contributes a lot
to
the results that we're seeing with STRO-004.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Hi. I have a two-part question about your correlation slide.
I saw on that correlation there were other targets
that may be unrelated, cadherin 3 and
TROP2. Was there a correlation between those targets
and efficacy?
So I mentioned earlier that the targeted set of genes that we look
at included ADC targets, and part of that is to assess
what might be targets that can be
co-targeted or what targets
might represent things that we could pursue in case there's some
resistance that mediated by loss of target.
And so right now we're not necessarily looking at them from a functional
perspective, but more of what the relationship of
these different target expressions might be.
So there wasn't a correlation between their expressions?
It's not a strong correlation. I think it just so happens, for example, that TROP2
is just really highly expressed in the lung models.
Some of them might be reflective of the
tumor types as well.
Okay. That's good. Thank you.
I have a question.
In the
cytotoxicity assay using
normal cells,
your antibody's safety profile is better.
So,
I wonder, is your antibody
is a cancer-selective antibody,
correct?
It is. So that's a
highly selected data set. But of course, we have a number of
experiments showing that STRO-004 does have higher
cytotoxicity in cancer cells.
Mm-hmm.
And there is some relationship to the level of target
as well.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, we hear often about bystander killing and the importance, especially in
clinical efficacy. We believe that's really key, and that can be through
intracellular generation and subsequent efflux of the payload or even
extracellular through secreted cathepsins.
Can you comment on whether that's a relevant factor here for
your beta-glucuronidase activated ADC, and
whether some of the variability in your responses in your models might
be due to the efficiency of processing in that model, or even
in the secretion of beta-glucuronidase into the extracellular
milieu, which might be very difficult to pick up with the methods that
you've been using to find markers? Yeah. Thank you.
I want to say that it's primarily, we rely on the tumor
selectivity of beta-glu because it's supposed to be highly expressed in tumor
settings. And so that coupled with the bystander
effect of exotecan, I think is mostly responsible for the
depth and the breadth of responses that we're seeing, because when we see it and
even in tissue factor low models, I think it's a
reflection of both of that.
The ADC does get into the tumor microenvironment, it's
processed, and then there can be bystander effect
resulting from that.
Yeah. So do you think extra tumoral beta-glucuronidase levels might
correlate with response in some way, and is that something that you can examine
with your 70 model panel?
The short answer is I don't know,
but I feel that in general,
beta-glu in the tumor, whether that's intracellular or potentially
extracellular, will or might contribute to the efficacy.
Again, we just haven't looked enough at where
exactly beta-glu is expressed. But we have data showing that it is
really upregulated in tumor microenvironment anyway.
Yeah. Thank you. Great work. Thank you.
Thank you.
Is there anything special about the antibody that you've done to reduce the
bleeding risk?
We screened it. So this antibody came from internal screening, and
we chose the ones that had the
lowest impact
on bleeding risk.
Hi, thanks for the great talk. Tissue factor is also expressed by several stromal
cells. In the
mass clinical trial you run, have you seen or characterize any
difference in terms of efficacy between epithelial or stromal dense
tumors?
So we haven't delved further into that yet.
We want to finish enrollment of the full study
before we look into additional factors and begin looking at different,
I guess, histologic features of our tumors.
So I don't have an answer for you yet.
Thank you.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Okay, so this concludes our mini symposium.
And at the beginning of this,
my co-chair pointed out that the field is no
longer asking whether we can drug a target, but we're
collectively asking whether we can design a system that can
succeed. And we'd like to thank the organizers for pulling
together this symposium and curating a wonderful set of
speakers that has shown us not only can we, but we are doing
that. We've heard a remarkable and yet cohesive set of
presentations today that take us from showing how the
antibody-drug conjugate field is moving from that first
generation, which had limitations from single targets,
static biology, as well as narrow therapeutic indexes,
and moving towards platforms that actively
engineer and can target a heterogeneous tumor
and overcome resistance and develop
payloads that have fewer pharmacologic
boundaries and limitations with pharmacokinetics.
And so from this, what we saw today was an emergence of
a few themes. And that is really that solving tumor
heterogeneity is through design and not
selection necessarily, and that our antibody drug
conjugate success is no longer dependent on that perfect
homogenous tumor environment, but it's through engineering
both therapeutic systems that can tolerate that heterogeneity.
We've also learned about that payload choice.
It's a strategic lever, and it's a strategic lever that can be
utilized and co-optimized with tumor resistance
biology. And then finally, we also learned that
avoiding those antigen sinks and targeted
therapeutics through
upregulating and being
mindful of those ADME and pharmacodynamic parameters are
very important, and that not only is it the
target expression alone, but it's the epitope selection, that tissue
distribution, as well as the geometry that matter just as
much as the affinity. So I'd really like to thank, once
again, our collection of speakers that have been absolutely fantastic
in underscoring and showing the emergence of this highly innovative
technology. And as you've seen, many still have posters and
presentations that you can go visit, and we hope to bring
more dialogue because there are some really innovative and
emerging concerns that bring us
to highlight the importance of even biomarker
delivery and the emerging therapies, and how do we tolerate
that in the face of targeting this heterogeneity.
But also, not only how does that translate into
the clinic, and how do we design those clinical trials
that build in to treat heterogeneity.
So I'd like to thank our speakers once again, and I appreciate your
attendance and a great discussion throughout each of these
conversations and discussions. Thank you.